what's going on guys this is rob and i
have a crazy idea it's so crazy i think
it's actually true
i think andrew garfield
is the other
which if he is
that guy is a monster
literally and power wise so here's the
thing right spoiler alert for a movie
that if you haven't seen by now you're
probably not going to see here's the
thing we know that we're going to get
like a gigantic spider-verse crossover
event and even if sony and marvel
studios haven't necessarily confirmed it
the writing's on the wall one they're
teasing the idea or toying with the idea
of creating an event that will basically
center around the villain no that's our
first clue the second clue which isn't
even really a clue so much is hey guys
this is happening is spider-man
into the spider-verse right it's
literally a movie where like miles
morales the animated version which to
this day i still say is one of the best
spider-man movies of all time but miles
morales spider-gwen and spider-man noir
and spider-ham and all those characters
they all team up right and then you go
into spider-man no way home and you
basically get the marvel cinematic
universe version of spider-verse right
or at least an end of the spider-verse
type event where you have three
spider-man from across the multiverse
that team up against a credible threat
which is basically the various villains
from their own universes here's what
makes this so cool the concept of
spider-verse came out of dan's slot
spider-man run which is the one that i
always suggest you guys read if you ever
want to get into spiderman right just
start with spider-man big time by dan
slott read forward make sure you read
through superior spider-man all the way
through all new all different marvel and
then basically the end of his run right
clone conspiracy so fantastic spider-man
run but before dan sloth picked up the
pen and started writing his run there
was a guy named j michael strozinski now
the last story that j michael strzenski
wrote was spider-man one more day you
guys have probably heard of this story
if for no other reason then the fact
that spider-man no way home was
initially rumored to be based off of
spider-man one more day we know now the
movie is actually based more on one
moment in time and brand new day but
when j michael strzinski originally
started writing spider-man what he did
is he introduced this concept called
spider totals now what are spider totems
okay so you know how like when t'challa
eats the heart-shaped herb and then
becomes the black panther and like meets
with the panther god bass and all that
kind of stuff he is basically an earthly
avatar of bast that's essentially what
spider totems are but on a much bigger
scale right because every universe has
its own version of best but there's only
one other there's only one bride one
scion and one master weaver across the
entirety of the multiverse so the way
this initially played out is that in the
comics this guy named ezekiel sims
showed up out of nowhere right and
basically told peter you are part of a
much bigger tapestry than you were
initially led to believe and a guy named
orlando is going to try to kill you
here's a bunker hide out there stay
there everything's going to be cool
peter said no peter ended up facing off
against moreland and to hear him
describe it the force behind more lens
punches was greater than that of the
incredible hulk right like more lun
punched harder than the hulk did which
was kind of nuts eventually peter parker
killed moreland more lund returned and
then moreland killed peter parker and
that's when the other manifested now the
other is basically this kind of soldier
of the spider totems right this guy that
exists to essentially guard all the
other spider totems and is like first
and foremost out there in front of
everybody the other had chosen peter
parker to be his avatar and this led to
peter parker his basically his dead body
being taken below the brooklyn bridge
and then being healed by the other and
peter parker was supposed to return
while his body was healed peter parker
rejected the other he got he said i
don't have anything to do with this and
so the other left peter parker and
bonded itself to a different spider-man
which eventually turned out to be kane
who's basically one of the clones of
peter from the clone side it doesn't
matter the important thing is the other
is basically the soldier now beyond that
what you have is the bride the bride
represents happenstance in the comics it
was a girl named cindy moon that she was
a girl who was in the same science class
as peter parker and just happened to be
standing next to peter parker when peter
was bitten by the radioactive spider
that in turn bit her now the way this
works is that in the multiverse in the
comics and again the marvel cinematic
universe probably won't follow this to a
t but given the nature of like toby and
andrew and tom it kind of looks like
they are in the comics what you have are
really patterns it's not truly fate uh
it kind of is maybe fate by a different
name but you basically have patterns
that whenever it comes to the spider-man
mythos and the comics it usually always
starts with peter parker that peter
parker is bitten by a radioactive spider
usually it's some kind of a an event
where he's attending a science exhibit
or he's going on some kind of a trip
with his class but the general theme is
always the same right that the
circumstances for andrew garfield the
circumstances for toby and the
circumstances for tom are not identical
but they're close enough right they're
all basically similar that across the
multiverse it's pretty much always the
same way the bride represents a
circumstance where that deviates so
spider-gwen for example right gwen stacy
was never really supposed to be bitten
by a radioactive spider but she was and
so she ended up becoming spider woman
there's an alternate reality where there
was no one to go to the science exhibit
with peter parker so uncle ben went with
peter and then uncle ben was bitten by a
radioactive spider the bride basically
represents a happenstance or
circumstance that's unlikely to happen
but basically results in someone other
than peter parker being bitten by a
radioactive spider or someone in
addition to peter parker being bitten by
a radioactive spider so you could have
some kind of a circumstance where the
spider's coming down it's this little
thread or whatever it is and then the
fan kicks off right and like the vent
the air from the vent pushes it like 50
feet in that direction and like tom
holland's teacher from spider-man
homecoming is the one who's bitten by a
radioactive spider right so the bride
represents that concept that very idea
the scion represents those individuals
who inherit their powers so as an
example in marvel comics you have a
universe called earth x which is a
ridiculously good story in fact the
eternals movie is actually borrowing
heavily from the earth x storyline but
the thing about this is that peter
parker has a daughter with mary jane
watson in that story and then she
inherits her spider powers she's not
bitten by a radioactive spider she
inherits them the scion represents that
hence the meaning behind the name scion
descended from a noble family descended
from the spider-man bloodline that's
happened multiple times over the comics
it happened in the old man logan
universe where individuals just inherit
their spider powers then you have the
master weaver now the master weaver is
arguably the most important and the
reason why is because the master weaver
literally just sits out there basically
and just like spins this thing called
the web of life and destiny now the web
of life and destiny you actually saw in
spider-man into the spider-verse the
animated movie with miles morales even
if you didn't know what it was that's
what that is so what is the web of life
and destiny well that's the thing that
unifies all the different spider totems
from across the multiverse and not just
spider totems every spider-man and
spider woman across the multiverse
sometimes they can sense these
connections other times they can't but
it basically unifies them all together
it's also a means of travel it's
basically a way to access the multiverse
so you could literally go to the master
weaver and say master weaver i want to
travel to like this universe here
somewhere and a portal will open
assuming he allows you to do it and you
travel through that portal and you're in
that universe now the the web of life
and destiny at least in the comics
anyway actually exists in a place called
earth one it's referred to as loom world
it was a world that was basically
conquered by the inheritors that's not
really important here what i think is
going on is i think right now in the
marvel cinematic universe and really
just in the overall spider-man movies as
a whole we have two out of the four
spider totems we have the master weaver
and we have the other the other i think
is andrew garfield because the other
usually visits and takes over a person
in a time of dire circumstance more so
than that the other actually amplifies
the emotional feelings of a person as
they're possessed by the other in the
case of andrew garfield he told us
explicitly after the death of gwen stacy
he stopped pulling his punches that he
became dark he became brutal that he
started like just pummeling and possibly
even killing some of the villains from
his own universe that's something the
other would do that's what cain did not
granted cain was already kind of a dick
to begin with but it amplified those
things right it made them more extreme
so it's not that hard to believe that if
andrew garfield was in a position to
where he was already emotionally
vulnerable that the other could have
easily possessed and taken over him he
becomes an avatar for it and then starts
to go to the extreme now whether or not
that means andrew garfield will be like
the comics version of the other where he
just like transforms into a giant spider
you know all super saiyan andrew
garfield i doubt it i doubt you're gonna
see that in the mcu i mean it's not
unreasonable right we're literally
talking about a line of movies that have
giant space gods that made androids that
turned out to be eternals and like a guy
that can turn into a giant green rage
monster right is it really that
unreasonable to believe that a person
could just turn into a giant spider at
this point all bets are off right
there's no rules anymore right let's
just do whatever it is that seems like
the coolest thing to do which i
absolutely love but beyond that i think
toby's the master weaver i think toby
mcguire is a master weaver because one
of the things he said in the movie is
that he could sense there was a
spider-man that needed help out there
now it seems kind of weird that it would
just be like i sensed it right i sensed
there was a spider-man that needed some
help or something like that and it kind
of put him on this sort of pedestal
unless it's served a purpose and that
the master weaver doesn't really do much
outside of like spin the web of life and
destiny and connect the different spider
avatars and spider totems together by
the various spiderman and spider women
but if toby was going to be any of those
guys it would be the master weaver that
he's basically represents this idea of
unification among all the different
spider-men and all the different spider
women across the entirety of the
multiverse and so when you have an event
where basically any version of peter or
a spider character out there loses what
we would consider to be their uncle ben
it's a significant event right that like
tom holland lost scott may that was his
equivalent of uncle ben right she told
him with great power must also come
great responsibility that solidified
that one line right there was basically
like holy cow this has all just been an
origin story damn what a way to do it
right it kind of solidifies all that but
it's also a significant thing it's one
of the things that's kind of been hit on
in marvel comics over the years that the
mcu may borrow is that the death of
uncle ben is always the big moment in
the life of peter parker that in the
alternate reality for example when uncle
ben became spider-man it was actually
the death of peter parker in aunt may at
the hands of the green goblin that was
his significant event right but always
like that big thing that totally changes
the character that initiates a paradigm
shift and moves them into a new
direction and so toby being able to
sense that and be like tom holland
losses on may i since there was a
spider-man you know in in very very in
in dire straits right i sensed a great
disturbance in the spider force like it
makes sense that he would be like the
master weaver right like he would be the
guy that basically kind of connects all
the different spider-man or the very
least can sense all the different
spider-man in terms of the other two the
scion and the bride i have no idea i
mean at this point it could be any of
the various spider characters that we've
seen right so the bride could be
spider-gwen right because it's usually
always spider-man or somebody like that
who's bitten by a radioactive spider it
could be the scion at the moment is like
miles morales or they could be
characters that we haven't even seen yet
i have no idea so here's my question to
you guys to end this video if you had to
pick a character to be the bride and a
character to be the scion in this whole
great big huge cosmic event that
marvel's doing that will most likely
build up to the events of like null the
symbiote god right because the venom
symbiote now exists in the marvel
cinematic universe which means null is
now aware of the marvel cinematic
universe's existence right assuming that
he's anything remotely close to his
comic book counterpart uh
who would it be right who would this
person be if it's this great big huge
multiversal event it's all leading to a
fight with null maybe something akin to
like venomverse or something like that
but it's going to be this gigantic
multiversal spiderman crossover event
who would the scion and who would the
bride be
or are they simply people that we
haven't seen yet so let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace